can we have a royal clap please
life has suddenly changed a lot for
pamela uber the 26 year old has been
thrust into the media spotlight more
than your typical beauty queen
the medical scientist who moved to
ireland from south africa in 2004 was
this week crowned the first black miss
ireland in the competition 74 years
do you think it's historic
it well it is you know they there's
never been somebody like me being miss
ireland so it definitely is um a very
significant point for ireland and
i hope that this just opens more doors i
was from county mayo which is
you know it's not like new york or
something so there's not a lot of us
around there but pamela's victory has
also attracted negative attention
especially through social media do you
experience much racism either online or
in real life here in ireland i do like
um you'd be surprised to i don't know if
you would be surprised actually but it
you would get a lot of bullying on
online racism online and i've
experienced it online quite a lot
especially since becoming miss galway
and then becoming miss ireland um it's
there is a minority there that feel the
need to
to put out negativity and all i can say
is that hurt people are the ones hurting
people and you should not let them get
into your bubble and break you down
after pamela's family moved to ireland
when she was seven they were placed in
direct provision ireland's widely
criticized and privately run
accommodation for asylum seekers the
uber family were left in this legal
limbo for 10 years
to be stuck in that
in that position for a long time is
it's very it's very damaging to a family
i know my family we were living in a
caravan for a year i was telling my mom
i'm
potentially going to be get sent back to
south africa where i would be selling
lemons or the street or something you
know that's how i felt as a child that i
was going back to nothing now an irish
citizen pamela wants the government to
fulfill its commitment to reform the
asylum system it's not the people
that
i'm talking about when i say that direct
provision is office it's the system that
i'm talking about
that that system needs changing
still getting used to her new crown the
former asylum seeker who made history is
now preparing to represent her country
at the miss world event in december
steven murphy sky news in dublin